huh what'd you say
culture gets mad cash for her fourth
birthday
there's no limit on how much cardi b and
offset are willing to shell out for
their little girl but wait till you hear
just how much what is that
it's a ticket a ticket is a million
girls
50 say 50.
you heard right culture gifted fifty
thousand dollars as she turns four years
old oh snappity snap snap while we pick
up our jaws off the floor check out the
b day festivities which were seriously
sweet literally birthday girl
yes i'm gonna buy you cotton candy it's
candy heaven cardi and offset take the
whole family to an interactive kids
museum called candytopia
you're ready to get at the boy
good job kk
and the marshmallow pit
[Applause]
from swings to see-saws culture is
living her best birthday life
at every corner culture and her brother
wade play at the sweet art exhibit
hand-crafted from thousands of pieces of
candy
yes squishy
no you cannot take it off
but culture isn't the only one having a
blast watch what happens when the wap
rapper sees a familiar face on display
[Music]
[Music]
seems like culture is equally impressed
once she recognizes her mom's
self-portrait what's that
yep
[Music]
yeah it's pretty standard for cardi and
offset to go all out for their kids b
days earlier this week the grammy winner
made a special request at her show in
england for her fans to sing to culture
and the crowd erupted
[Applause]
and over the years cultures had her
share of extravagant affairs oh good
you're so beautiful
last year when she turned three culture
was pretty in pink as she rode in on a
horse-drawn carriage fit for a princess
happy birthday
happy birthday
happy birthday
look look at the castle
inside the princess themed party there
were over-the-top details a barbie
display and even real-life disney
princesses and we saw priceless moments
of culture in her parents including a
sweet daddy daughter dance
she's so precious seriously keeping with
the luxe vibes back in 2020 culture got
a birken bag at just two years old
wow it's pretty
cool
look look
[Music]
some critics were quick to slam guardian
offset for the lavish gift since a
burkitt can cost thousands and thousands
of dollars but cardi she had a good
reason behind kk's gift if on fly
and daddy's fly
and then so is the kid i'm not mad that
daddy bought baby a broken she gonna
match mommy and to be fair cardi and
offset can do what they want with their
money which is why we're not surprised
culture got stacks on stacks for this
birthday happy birthday baby girl
huh what'd you say
[Music]
you